qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire vos bouquins
ou 34 sec de surlonge s'il vous plaît
autre chose
la jetta ce que les frac on vient de
recevoir 16 1385 chacun ça c'est la
version française de cette plus regarder
dès maintenant la version anglaise
croyances rafraîchissent déjà la police
vous avez bien entendu
quatorze 1990 dollars en anglais seize
mille 385 dollars en français les
francophones paierait-il 1395 dollars de
plus que les anglophones pour la même
jetta pas du tout la différence 2395
dollar entre les deux publicités
représentent les frais de transport et
de préparation au québec
la loi oblige les commerçants a annoncé
un prix tout inclus les téléspectateurs
anglophones verront donc lui aussi 16000
385 dollars pour cette jetta
sauf que eux ne le savent pas parce que
la version anglaise de cette pub
respectent pas la loi québécoise